إذن أنت تقول أن هذا هو الشيء الصحيح الذي ينبغي عمله
وكان هذا أمرًا لا مفر منه فيما يتعلق
بتأمين
السلام ولكني أريد أن أتحدث عن
الضحايا هنا لأننا رأينا ثمانية
أشخاص يموتون وشاهدنا العديد من
الإصابات أيضًا، ما هو
فهمك؟  ملف تعريف الأشخاص
الذين لقوا حتفهم، نعم،
ليس ثمانية أشخاص، بل ثمانية
إرهابيين تم التعرف على الأسلحة والبنادق،
لذا فهم جميعًا
إرهابيون،
حسنًا، سبعة من الثمانية كانوا
يحملون أسلحة أثناء مقتلهم،
لذلك لا أعرف شيئًا عن ذلك  عمرك لكنك
تعلم على ما يبدو أنهم كانوا في نفس
المنطقة ولكن هؤلاء الرجال لم يكونوا
مدنيين أبرياء، كما تعلم، نحن نرسل رسائل نصية
مسبقًا نطلب فيها من المدنيين البقاء
في منازلهم، ونحن نتخذ
الاحتياطات اللازمة للتأكد من عدم وقوع أي
إصابات بين المدنيين، لا يمكننا ذلك  نضمن
ذلك ولكننا نبذل قصارى جهدنا للقيام بذلك
ولكن دعنا نتحدث عن
الأشخاص الثمانية الذين لقوا حتفهم، فأنت تقول إنهم
ثمانية إرهابيين، لذا فأنت تؤكد
أن الوفيات الآن
لا تشمل الضحايا المدنيين
جيدًا.  يمكنني أن أؤكد لك أن سبعة من
الثمانية كانوا يحملون أسلحة ونحن
نطلق النار على قواتنا بشكل جيد ولذا أه
بالتأكيد يمكنني تقديم التزام بشأن
هؤلاء السبعة ولكني أعتقد أن
الثامن أيضًا كان متورطًا ولكن ليس لدي
معلومات اليوم ولكن يمكنني أن أخبركم
أن قادتنا يبذلون كل ما
في وسعهم للتأكد من أننا
نهاجم الإرهابيين وسمعنا
الإرهابيين
نعم أعني أن هناك أيضًا 50 شخصًا
أصيبوا حتى نعرف
الوضع على  الأرض أصبحت
شديدة للغاية، لقد رأيتم
الإدانة القادمة من مختلف
البلدان، ومصر أيضًا وقفت بثبات، هل
أنتم قلقون من
احتمالية تأثير ذلك على علاقتكم أه
مع بعض الدول العربية وخاصة
تلك التي وقعتم معها اتفاقيات أبرام
حسنًا، لدينا علاقات قوية مع تلك
الدول التي يفهمونها لأنها
تواجه الإرهاب أيضًا في
المنطقة من نفس الجماعات المتطرفة
وهم يدركون أنه ليس لدينا
خيار آخر، كما تعلمون أنه ليس في
نيتنا أن نكون هناك ولكن عندما نعرف
عن ذلك  التهديدات ونحن نعلم عن
القدرات وأعتقد أن أي دولة أخرى
في العالم وليس فقط في المنطقة
ستفعل نفس الشيء ولن تعتمد التهديدات
على هؤلاء المدنيين هل أه
نعرف عنها أي شيء
من حيث هل كانت هناك
مناقشات مع واشنطن  حول هذه
الغارة وما إذا كانت الولايات المتحدة قد أعطت
الضوء الأخضر
جيدًا، فنحن لسنا بحاجة إلى ضوء أخضر من
أي شخص ولكن لدينا حوار مفتوح
مع زملائنا في واشنطن، كما
تعلمون أننا نشارك معهم الكثير من
المعلومات الاستخباراتية التي نجمعها في  المنطقة
ولدينا تعاون جيد معهم، لذا
نعم نحن نتحدث مع زملائنا
في العاصمة ولكننا لا نطلب حياة جيدة، كما
تعلمون أن هذه هي سياستنا، وأي
حكومة في إسرائيل ستتخذ
القرارات الصحيحة لحماية المدنيين لدينا،
ونحن لا نفعل ذلك.  "لسنا بحاجة إلى سلطة ليس من
الولايات المتحدة وليس من الاتحاد الأوروبي وليس من الأمم المتحدة
حسنًا، تقول الأمم المتحدة هاستينغز أم وهي
منسقة الشؤون الإنسانية المقيمة قالت إنها شعرت بالقلق من
حجم هذه العملية، هل تقبل
هذا التوصيف،
لا أعتقد أن الكثير من الناس  انظروا، كما تعلمون،
قفزنا إلى الاستنتاجات وما
رأيناه في الساعات القليلة الماضية هو أن لدينا
عملية دقيقة للغاية ونحن
حذرون للغاية بشأن استخدام القوة
ونركز على مطاردة الإرهابيين
في مختبرات الإرهاب التي بنوها في
جنين.  المنطقة لذلك لا أعتقد أن هناك أي
سبب لإدانتنا ولكن كما تعلم، بعض
الأشخاص لا ينظرون إلى التفاصيل
عندما يرون بعض أنشطة
قواتنا فإنهم يدينوننا على الفور